die strahlungs opfer wurden wohl in ein
naheliegendes krankenhaus gebracht und
niemand dort wurde vorgewarnt vollkommen
unbedacht wurde mit dem patienten
umgegangen und dabei das pflegepersonal
zusätzlich verstrahlt hier die details
zum atomunfall die neuen details bei
ging es um science-fiction hier gibt's
täglich spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal und aktiviert die
glocke nur dann verpasst ihr kein video
los geht's auch immer mehr details
werden zu dem musischen atomunfall
bekannt jetzt meldete sich ein arzt aus
dem gebiets krankenhaus in archangelsk
bei spiegel-online dort wurden die opfer
zunächst behandelt die umstände der
einlieferung und der behandlung erinnern
dabei wieder an den atomunfall in
tschernobyl hier nochmal die
begleitumstände explodiert ist wohl der
flüssigtreibstoff des neuen
marschflugkörper sss cx-9 sky voll
er wird aber wohl zusätzlich noch atomar
angetriebene beim test zur umschaltung
zwischen konventionell und atomar einen
antrieb könnte der unfall passiert seien
dabei wurden sieben mitarbeiter getötet
drei der opfer wurden dabei in das
gebiets krankenhaus in los angeles
eingeliefert bevor zwei von ihnen an den
folgen der strahlung starben
das berichtet the moscow times unter
anderem niemand wusste von der
verstrahlung und anstatt sie zu
dekontaminieren wurden die verletzten
erst einmal für operationen vorbereitet
und das geschah alles vollkommen
ungeschützt erst auf dem operationstisch
wurde die strahlungsbelastung gemessen
und die war so hoch dass die operation
erst mal nicht gemacht wurden
stattdessen wurden die opfer erst mal
gebadet die wanne soll danach so
kontaminiert gewesen sein dass sie
entsorgt werden musste inzwischen hat
der inlandsgeheimdienst laut the moscow
times alles beschlagnahmt was mit dem
unfall zu tun hat und das personal
verschwiegenheitserklärung
unterschreiben lassen alles in allem
wundert einen diese geheimniskrämerei
und die damit verbundene gefährdung von
noch mehr menschen insgesamt scheint der
atomunfall nur lokal zu einer hohen
strahlenbelastung geführt zu haben in
norwegen wurde jetzt lediglich eine
minimal erhöhte strahlung gemessen und
auch beim medizinischen personal wurde
nur eine geringe belastung festgestellt
trotzdem löst dieser unfall unschöne
erinnerungen an tschernobyl aus und
natürlich die
die belegschaft im krankenhaus ist
verunsichert weil nichts ist sicher
außer dass alles unsicher ist weil sie
ja keine informationen bekommen lieber
gefährdet man in russland die eigene
bevölkerung als dass man sie warnt und
schützt und auch im nachhinein ist kaum
etwas zu erfahren wie auch beim
atomunfall in majak 2017 über den wir
berichtet haben wird es wohl wieder
jahre dauern bis wirklich gewissheit da
ist was da in russland passiert ist hier
in deutschland widmet man sich gerade
für einen größeren atomunfall mögliche
atomunfall deutschland sorgt vor und
kauft 190 millionen jodtabletten
anklicken anschauen und bitte mein
zweikanal klick zum nature abonnieren da
würde ich mich sehr darüber freuen bis
dann bleibt dran